- Hi, everyone.
I'm really excited to
welcome Genie Yoo here today,
because her work on
colonial era natural history
in the Dutch East Indies promises
to resonate with scholars
across Yale who are
interested in Southeast Asia,
the environmental humanities,
human nature interactions,
science and technology studies,
colonial history and more.
Genie Yoo is a PhD candidate
in history at Princeton University
and currently a short-term fellow
at the John Carter Brown Library,
you can see from the background,
that library in the background.
She's trained in early
modern and modern history
of Island Southeast Asia,
and works at the intersection
of history of science,
medicine, religious studies,
and the history of the book.
She's completing her
dissertation, "Mediating Islands,
Ambon Across the Ages"
under the supervision
of Michael Laffan and Keith Wailoo.
And she's also the author
of a very powerful article
called "Wars and Wonders:
"The Inter-Island Information Networks
"of Georg Eberhard Rumphius"
published in the British Journal
for the History of Science,
as well as numerous fascinating
and well-written book reviews.
Please join me in welcoming
Genie Yoo for today's talk,
which is entitled, "Paper
Chains from Fields to Archives:
A View of the Information
Economy in 18th Century
Colonial Indonesia."
Genie.
- Thank you so much, Erik,
and thank you to everyone
who's attending today
and to the council on Southeast
Asian studies at Yale,
and of course, to Kris Mooseker
who helped to organize this
since the summer.
Today, I'll be presenting on a small part
of the fourth chapter for my dissertation,
which explores how cross-cultural
exchange shaped European
and indigenous knowledge formations
about unbalance natural
world from the 17th
to the 20th century.
And what I'll be presenting
today takes us back
to the 18th century.
Let me share my...
So Paper Chains from Fields to Archives:
A View of the Local Information Economy
in the 18th Century Colonial Indonesia.
Assam Soliman was not a
man of quiet disposition,
or so the documents would have us believe.
Soliman's voice captured in translation
came roaring across the
pages of company records,
copied again and again
in the 18th century.
The year was 1705, a clear
day in the month of May,
the beginning of the
year's drawing season.
Captain Lieutenant De
Bevere who had traveled
to the province of Ambon
for a council meeting
had no idea that what
he was about to witness
would make any kind of impact
on future Dutch East India
Company considerations.
According to De Bevere,
an uncommon commotion
marked what was supposed to
be a routine council meeting
in one of the Island's
most lucrative provinces.
Assam Soliman cause
high status at Orankaya
guaranteed them a seat at the council
had protested vociferously
against new company demands.
The company was demanding
that administrators
lower the production of
cloves on the island.
This was partly a response
to an intractable problem
rankling the Dutch East India
Company's high government
in Batavia.
Millions of pounds of
stored cloves were rotting
and administrators could
neither sell them for profit
nor leave them to decay
in the humid spaces
of the city's cramped warehouses.
One of the ways to keep
this problem at bay,
at least momentarily, was
to reduce the total number
of fresh cloves shipped from Ambon,
where they were mainly
produced to Batavia and Java,
the center of VOC operations
in the East Indies.
Soliman was flabbergasted
in hearing the demand
so counterintuitive to
company expectations
for the past century, during
which time the islands people
had become economically dependent
on the company's commerce and cloves.
The Ambonese, Soliman emphasized
had labored tirelessly
for years to meet the
demands of the company
despite their "suffering and
neglect of their own trees."
But now the company
wanted the very opposite.
Exasperated, Soliman
was to have explained,
"Are we not now poor enough?
"What is so hard about letting
them know of our condition?
"Just let them load the ships
with ropes to strangle us,
"then we shall deal with
more of these cloves
"and then some."
The islands administrators
impeded in significance
to Soliman's retort.
On the last day of May,
1705, the governor of Ambon,
a man named Balthasar Coijet
sent a letter marked secret
to administrators in Batavia.
In it he described me as he
had heard from De Beveres
who supposedly repeated
Soliman word for word in Dutch.
Now it is impossible to know
if this was what Soliman
had actually said at the council meeting.
If he was indeed protesting the decrease
in the production of
cloves, why would he say,
then we shall deal with more
of these cloves and then some.
Well there's reasons for doubt, Coijet
exceeded confidence in its fidelity.
He mentioned that De Bevere who witnessed
and belayed at this
incident would soon testify
to its veracity in person
by "word of mouth,"
since he was already on
a ship bound for Batavia.
While this may sound somewhat dramatic,
this was relatively
speaking in minor event
in the history of Ambon.
However, it has an important
bureaucratic afterlife
in the VOC provincial archive in Batavia.
The contents of Coijet's
letter would be extracted
and copied in company reports,
demonstrations, resolutions,
and considerations.
This was in part a coincidence,
but it also happened
at a time when the company
was honing a complex system
of information collection and retrieval
through their active use of past documents
from provincial archives.
Just four years after the
incident was recorded,
a man by the name of Joan Van Hoorn,
a prominent administrator in Batavia
who would soon become the
VOC's governor general
extracted Soliman's retort
from Coijet's letter in full,
and included it in assigned demonstration
to the high government.
This was only the beginning.
A chain of paperwork would
carry Soliman's words
deep into the recesses of the
company's provincial archive
in Batavia, allowing them
to resurface intermittently
throughout the century.
Van Hoorn's lengthy
demonstration would be copied
word for word into the
book of general resolutions
for that year.
This rendered the incident
and the coded traces
of Soliman's words we
treatable and extractable
through the use of what
would eventually be known
as the Realia Repertorium,
a working index of select marginalia
from the high government's
daily resolutions.
Assam Soliman's name
would appear yet again
in the latter half of the 18th century.
In 1775 report about
cultivating Bandas native
nutmeg trees in Ambon.
So 70 years after Coijet related
in a secret letter in 1705,
Soliman's words would
be used in this report
but reinterpreted under vastly
different circumstances.
Since the 16th century,
natural expeditions
were one of the main sources
of European information
gathering in the East Indies.
Expensive, but valuable such expeditions
became a ubiquitous part
of imperial activities
in the early modern period.
Producing a wealth of books, descriptions,
drawings and paintings
about plants and animals,
minerals, and stones,
people their cultures.
As many have argued,
they conveyed information
advantageous for global commerce,
significant for scholarship
and useful for empires.
In this respect, the 18th
century was no different.
Marked as it was by
voyages global dimensions,
the most famous of which were
newly sponsored expeditions
for the gathering of natural historical,
as well as ethnographic
knowledge and specimens
for trade and for scholarship.
This presentation asks a
slightly different question.
After a century or more of collecting
and the Dutch East Indies,
how was past knowledge about
the natural world retrieved
and how was it read as information
having present economic value
pertinent to global commerce.
While explorers and administrators
continue to undertake expeditions,
others began to rely on their
own provincial archives,
re-interpreting the past
and their present context
of the 18th century to
create considerations
pertinent to their governance
in the archipelago.
There are three main questions
I would like to address today,
inspired by this bureaucratic afterlife
of Assam Soliman's words.
First, what were the archival
strategies of VOC clerks
who retrieved information from the past?
In other words, how did
administrators read to govern?
Second and more specifically,
how did the active extraction
of past information from the archive
affect colonial governance?
And third, how might the
history of the VOC's active use
of material archives at the
site of colonial governance
help us to understand
their attempt to sustain
the political economy of the
VOC during its rapid decline
towards the end of the 18th century?
The answers to these questions
are I believe connected.
And I'm going to
demonstrate it in two parts.
First, I'm going to show
how VOC clerks, marginalists
and archivists created an
actively used a new system
of information retrieval
in the 18th century,
a system which involved the
use of a massive working index.
Then I will address how
retrieved information
from past documents were
integrated into new reports,
which influenced
administrative considerations
about labor in particular,
towards the end of the 18th century,
a time when the company was
completely drowning in debt,
no longer fruitfully
invested in inter-Asian trade
and crippled by inter
Imperial competition.
VOC scribes understood that being able
to retrieve information
was just as important as collecting them.
The retrieval of information
about a specific thing
from the company's vast archive
proved to be a formidable task.
This was because the
company's daily log books
and resolutions have been
recorded and preserved by date.
Chronology in short, formed
the organizational backbone
of the archive, and written information
lived under the shadow of concrete dates.
And recognizing the need
for a more efficient system
of information retrieval,
administrators in the 18th century
began to create an alphabetical
index of specific things
and names like cloves and
letters, nutmeg and quicksilver.
Over the course of the century,
they compiled an overwhelming number
of paratextual materials about real things
and places from the
company's handwritten tones
of general resolutions.
As the company's collecting
activities continued
and papers accumulated,
these indexes became a valuable tool,
a guide for reaching back,
not just into any past,
but the past of material things.
The first page of these
handwritten indexes
still preserved in Jakarta,
or the title general register
of the order of the alphabet
in the order of the alphabet,
which in the 19th century,
it was printed as one master index
of three volumes enlightened,
titled Realia Repertorium.
In organizing a system
of information retrieval
by way of an index, clerks were beholden
to the extent marginalia
that summarized a much lengthier passages
in the body of the resolutions.
Since each indexed item of
marginalia was accompanied
by a specific date, a clerk
could have easily found
the full resolution by
looking at the pertinent day
in the book of general
resolutions for that year.
Towards the end of the 18th century,
most certainly in the year 1789 and 1790,
a group of clerks in
Batavia created a collection
of extracted passages from resolutions
dated between 1703 and 1719.
The collection concern
one matter in particular,
the prodigious rot of
millions of pounds of cloves
in Batavia's warehouses,
which was partly why Assam Soliman
was asked to lower the
production of cloves in Ambon
back in 1705.
Behind this history of
how early 18th century
administrators manage
the city's vast amount
of decaying waste lies a
history of how late 18th century
VOC clerks were able to
retrieve that information
from an equally vast amount of paper.
In this case, one can actually
retrace how clerks retrieve
the past of information from the index
and its list of dated
marginalia for cloves
to original counts from
the company's annual book
of general resolutions,
out of which they created
selected extracts.
The clerk's names signed on
every document they copied
or checked, where the only clues
to the time of its collection.
In other words, the date of
the retrieval is not mentioned
in these papers, only the date pertaining
to the index marginalia is noted.
Here's an example.
In the first two full use that the bundle
I've bee working with here on
the left side of the slide,
one finds a list of succinct descriptions,
all numbered, dated, checked
off and all having to do
with how the company attempted
to reduce the presence
of rotting cloves in the city.
Upon closer inspection, it is
clear that these descriptions
are marginalia selected from the index.
And are at least similar
to if not an exact copy
of the marginalia found
in the corresponding pages
of the general resolutions.
I'll take the first
marginalia to show exactly
what the clerk would
have had to do with it.
In 1789, a clerk by the
name of Leonard Duriguzzij
must have spent some time
thumbing through the book of
general resolutions from 1703.
Duriguzzij was one of 300 clerks working
for the company that year.
And his name was included
in the annual name book
of the company's sworn servants.
Having received instructions
to extract the resolution
pertaining to the index marginalia,
Duriguzzij what I first scanned
the top of the first 70
pages of the resolutions
table of contents
before finding the page
numbers for the year 1703.
Upon finding the month of
June at the top of the page,
he would have scanned it's left margin
for the specific date.
And upon arriving at the 15th,
he would have seen a
brief list of marginalia
about the day's proceedings.
If he had bothered to peruse these at all,
he might've learned
that on June 15th, 1703,
the Tavion administrators
have discussed the shipments
of sun kissed silver and
gold brought into Batavia
from Bengal and the Coromandel coast.
He might've also noticed
that on the same distant day,
a ship loaded with animals
sailed for the city of Palembang
located on Sumatra's east coast,
for the express purpose of hauling pepper.
He would have also that
25,000 pounds of white pepper
were loaded in a vessel bound for Holland.
But as interesting as these
snippets might've been,
Duriguzzij was solely
charged with finding an entry
to the marginalia about cloves.
More specifically, he
was looking for some clue
as to how "the mixing
of moist and dry cloves
"have been found to be detrimental
"for this Batavia's climate."
To be sure, Duriguzzij found
that administrators in Batavia
faced a problem with the
cloves that had been stored
in the city's warehouses.
They had discussed this matter in relation
to the ongoing exports of tree bark
that were to be contrasted
with the demand for spices
from the Western sphere of the East Indies
were Persian and Gujarati
ships remained active.
Having inspected the warehouse stocks,
administrators offered a reflection
as to "the concept of mixing
the moist with the dry cloves,"
deciding that would be
best to separate them,
given the local climate in Batavia.
Moreover, presuming that the
dry ones remained of quality,
these were to be shipped
separately for sale.
Duriguzzij copied this
passage from the resolutions.
His own copy and extract was then approved
and signed by the head
clerk, Philippas De Elwyk.
Like other company clerks
working under De Elwyk,
Duriguzzij signed his name
on the bottom left corner
of the document innately curling
the first and last letters,
but abbreviating his first name
as what as was common practice.
Now suffice it to say that
these clerks eventually found
that between 1703 and 1719,
administrators in Batavia
tested various labor intensive methods
to rid the city of rotting cloves.
First forcing a group of
people referred in some parts
as are biters workers, and
in other parts of Slava
or slaves to stuff millions
of pounds of rotting cloves
under the city's bulwarks,
to ultimately be moving them years later,
forcing the same group
of people to ship them
to nearby islands and dumping
them in huge man-made holes,
nine feet underground.
This process took around two decades.
In the process of creating
extracts, clerks actively decided
on which passages to include
from the body of the resolutions,
which always had more information,
more details of methods
and accountings of figures
then were ultimately included.
The extracts would be to copies
of more selective fragments,
which would then be weaved
into other company reports.
One genre of which was
called the consideration.
The consideration was one of
many administrative genres
which exuberantly
referenced the paper past.
We pleat with fragments of
extracts of past resolutions
using the index, as well as past letters,
contemporary field reports
and handwritten extracts of printed books.
And I did so in order to
argue for new regulations,
as I will show 17th century
expertise would be invoked,
particularly when discussing
matters of the natural world.
It stakes for Imperial commerce
and the necessary labor
required to carry out
the production of spices
in the context of local
colonial governance.
In December 22nd, 1775,
the Tavion administrators
Willem Breton and Hendrick Fockens,
signed their names on the last page
of a completed consideration.
They had drafted up over
the course of one month,
since having received rain
near the clerks November
field report regarding the
present state of Ambon.
The chain of these administrative reports
concerned a problem that had a fraught,
if not an obscure past.
The cultivation of nutmeg trees
outside of their native Banda islands.
The clerk revealed that in
his report that in fact,
this was not the first time
the company had felt the need
to experiment with nutmeg
cultivation on foreign soil.
Using past letters and best solutions,
he revealed that back in 1695
when a series of devastating
earthquakes disrupted nutmeg
and maize production in
Banda, the high government
had inquired about sustaining
their production elsewhere,
a question of enormous consequence,
considering the company's
century long efforts
to monopolize these very
spices in the Banda islands
for global commerce.
Ultimately after much back and forth,
they settled for the island of Ambon,
reasoning that the Ambonese
people were more experienced
in matters of plant cultivation,
particularly of cloves.
In 1775 Breton and Fockens would learn
from this turn of the century experiment
of nutmeg transplantation.
The specialized knowledge of
preparing nutmeg and maize
from raw fruit parts to
commercially valuable spices
was not so easily transferable,
not even among people from
the same subset of islands
in the same region.
The short-lived, but exhaustive experiment
turned out to be a failure.
By using the clerks field
report, along with extracts
from books, treatises,
correspondences, demonstrations,
and resolutions, Breton and Fockens
would learn from this history
and to make their own judgments
on how best to execute
this delicate operation and their present.
What did they learn from extracts
of 17th century ethnographic
and natural historical writings was this.
Nutmegs ripe in twice a year in Banda.
Their ripeness revealed itself
through the natural splitting
of the nuts wooden shell,
which revealed the mace,
so clear red against the cool black
of the nuts outer layers.
In the morning, the enslaved
people at the islands
local overseers, who had
direct relations with the VOC
would make their way up the mountain
to the high altitudes
where trees flourished
in the mineral rich soil
surrounding the islands
active volcanoes.
Arriving at the forest, they
would spend their mornings
and afternoons "plucking."
Looking up into the sky among the branches
of the nutmeg trees,
they would have seen the red
mace in the crack of the hole,
and these they knew were
right for the plucking.
They also picked the overripe fruit,
which had fallen to the ground overnight
and would drop these
into a separate basket.
They knew not to confuse
the fleshly plucked
from the already fallen,
as the two kinds were to be
sold at different prices.
Around five in the afternoon,
they walked back down the mountain,
each carrying heavily
loaded baskets of the fruit,
which had to be prepared into spices.
This painstaking work involved, cracking,
unspooling, curing and drying the fruit,
a process which took in
total at least 12 weeks.
The extracted passages
detail how in the evenings,
the enslaved sharpen their knives
to crack the hard, thick,
outer layer of the fruit
completely open.
The cracking proved to
be a difficult process.
They had to apply just the
right amount of pressure
to cut through the
fruits, shell, and flesh,
but to leave the mace and nut intact.
Based on the abstract, this procedure
was considered dangerous.
Sometimes with a little too much pressure,
the knife would slice all the way through,
which not only left the
nut and mace in pieces,
but also "did away with
the slaves finger or two."
The enslaved also use their
hands to "unspool the red mace
"from the nut, vein by vein."
Furthermore, the 17th century
method of drying nutmegs
required the use of
indigenous technologies,
a complex infrastructure built solely
for applying varying
degrees of heat continuously
for six weeks, then came
the caulking process.
The enslaved would mix salt
water with a type caulk
of creating a special liquid solution
into which each dried nutmeg
would be dipped three times.
The skills, technologies and
knowledge needed to carry out
this long and delicate
process from the plucking
and the cracking,
to the unspooling, drying and the caulking
were exactly what rendered the experiment
of cultivating nutmegs outside of Banda
so "rare and difficult."
As Breton and Fockens learned,
sitting in Batavia in 1775,
back in 1699, administrators
considered bringing to Ambon
a number of "Bandanese overseers"
and a few slaves who understood that work.
The slave say wrote would
be able to impart in time
the knowledge of how to
handle the trees and fruit
to the indigenous Ambonese people.
But they complained
even after having given
enough courses and lessons,
the Ambonese seemed to have
lost "the will and diligence"
to carry out the work.
They claim that compared
to the slaves from Banda,
the Ambonese were "too
lazy, proud and useless"
to understand the special treatment
and knowledge necessary
for cultivating nutmegs.
Such turn of the century comparisons
between slaves from Banda
and laborers and Ambon
influenced Breton and Fockens in 1775,
as they considered how best
to gather enough manpower
for the task at hand.
The two administrators, however
were not entirely convinced
that the Ambonese were
simply "lazy and useless."
After all they argued,
it was the cultivating
and preparing cloves for the company
for more than a century.
They were also unconvinced
of the impossibility
of imparting the skills
and knowledge needed
to cultivate and prepare nutmegs,
and what they called the bunnies way.
While they accepted these
impressions and repeated them
in their own report, they began to search
for an explanation, and
then there are search
they came across the name Assam Soliman,
whose verbal retort against
the company back in May, 1705
left its own paper trail in
Batavia's provincial archive.
In 1709, four years after
the recorded incidents
at the council meeting with
which I began this presentation,
Joan Van Hoorn included an
extract of the secret letter
from Ambon his own demonstration.
Van Hoorn's main purpose
for writing in 1709
was to use Soliman as an
example of what he deemed
to be the declining
character of the Ambonese
for which she blamed the company
and it's focused on commerce.
It was what he called the
address of company ministers,
which have tainted the
local people with greed.
Moreover, because of this, he continued,
it would be difficult to
force the to do anything
without a fence or marked commotion.
To provide evidence, he cited
Soliman's retort word for word
from the original letter.
"Are we not now poor enough?
"What is so hard about letting
them know of our condition?
"Just let them load the shifts
with ropes to strangle us,
"and we shall deal with more
of these cloves and then some."
His demonstration would be copied in full
into the high government's
general resolutions
for the year 1709, and
through its insertion
into the canon of resolutions,
which clerks consulted
throughout the 18th
century using the index
as I have previously discussed,
it would come to resurface
in Breton and Focken's own report.
In their search for the
labor needed to cultivate
nutmegs in Ambon Breton and
Fockens too came came to focus
on the influence of
commerce on the character
of the indigenous people.
Echoing Van Hoorn, they
claim that the Ambonese
had left European yearning,
that is the particular ethic
of merchants whose sole
goal was to make a profit.
Such yearnings, however,
were no longer linked
to notions of greed, but to
the ideal of productivity.
Citing the resolution, which
included Van Hoorns reference
to the secret letter, Breton and Fockens
quoted Soliman's retort,
and recast this mediated
information from the past,
in the 1775 report to suit the principles
of the market economy.
They recommended that in
order to satisfy the Ambonese
as a workforce, administrators
would have to instill
commercial incentives.
The clerk had initially
advised the administrators
to pay the Ambonese
"with a gift of money."
One that would be "calculated
according to the supply
"of the previous five years."
Breton and Fockens vehemently disagreed.
They believed that calculations
based on the previous
five years would not be satisfactory.
This hinged on another
assumption about how local people
understood timing and
motivation as they claimed
that "the indigenous sees in the present
"as much as in the future."
Rather than paying them
based on bundled calculations
from the past then, they
recommended that the company
pay them based on a fixed
amount per weight of production.
For the two administrators,
the successful cultivation
of nutmegs had everything to
do with instilling motives
and that transferring
knowledge hinged on increasing
local peoples incentives.
Such on the ground considerations
and thinking about knowledge,
labor, money and incentives
and controlling the labor
force in the 18th century
may perhaps explain why at a
time when there was an acute
shortage of VOC coins,
the company would begin
to print paper money, not only in Batavia,
but also in Ambon in
both Dutch and in Malay
towards the end of the 18th century.
The two administrators differed
from their predecessors
in key ways.
While they agreed that 17 send few methods
of preparing the fruit into a
spice was a delicate operation
of extensive expertise in training,
they disagreed about the impossibility
of transferring such knowledge.
For them, this was not
a matter of character,
but a matter of economic motive.
Furthermore, they were keenly aware
of the company's overwhelming
reliance on Ambonese labor
for the success of their project.
This presentation has dipped
into one or two key moments
to assess how the emergence
of an 18th century
system of information
retrieval within Batavia
allowed officials to reach into the past
in a manner unprecedented to
device on the ground solutions
for specific problems.
It is indeed an intensely
local case of paper chains
from a provincial archive in Batavia,
but also of individuals whose
voices are metaphorically
chained to the papers,
which would be replicated
within the system.
I outlined it was this
process of converting
natural historical and
ethnographic information
into economically and
commercially valuable information,
which would ultimately
inform other reports
that made their way up the
chain from Batavia to Amsterdam,
as administrators in the provinces,
as well as the metrical
deliberated on how to revive
past cultivation and
transplantation practices
for their present dilemmas.
In effect, these
administrators became producers
and reproducers of information
that fed an ever-growing paper bureaucracy
lending the last to accompany,
which was by the last half
of the 18th century, drowning in debt
and crippled by interim material wars
across the Indian ocean.
During this process, information contained
within various administrative writings
came to have a protracted
lifespan as they were recycled
and extracts over the
course of the century.
I hope this shows the power
of provincial archives
for historical actors
'cause zone prognostications
were based on fragments
of mediated information
from a different time.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much, Genie.
Let's take a moment everyone
to reflect on this talk
for a moment while you
come up with questions.
We'll start the Q&A in just a moment or so
as people gather their thoughts.
That was a very rich and
wonderful presentation.
Thank you very much.
To the guests here, I
will moderate the Q&A.
If you have a question, please
use the hand raise function,
or turn your video on
and wave your hand wildly
and I'll probably see you that way too.
Michael, I see that you have
you've turned your video on.
Does that indicate an
interest in asking a question?
- Absolutely.
Thank you.
This fascinating talk.
You have published on Rumphius
who was one of the great
encyclopedic compilers of
information of the 17th century.
So, listening to you talk,
I'm wondering if there's any evidence
that some of these VOC bureaucrats
and archivist referenced
either any of his methods
or his reports to Batavia
or in the 18th century,
his publications, because of
course on spice production,
he was for a time probably
the world's expert
for that part of the world.
- Yeah, thank you so much,
Michael, for the question.
I have indirect evidence that
VOC administrators in Batavia
were using information
which Rumphius had collected
back in the 17th century,
mainly through their use
of Francois Valentines,
all the new East Indies.
And as we know, Valentine
was intimately connected
to Rumphius and derived
a lot of his own writings
about spices from Rumphius' works.
Rumphius' natural history
as herbal wasn't published
until the middle of the
18th century in Holland.
The print itself wasn't
as famous until the 19th
and 20th centuries when
it would we circulate
back to the islands to influence renewed
by a prospecting activities and Ambon.
But for the 18th century, I
don't have direct evidence
of VOC clerks in Batavia
using Rumphius' works.
They mainly site Valentine who at the time
is much more famous for
his printed ethnography.
But I wouldn't be surprised
if they were influenced
by not Rumphius' natural histories,
but as administrative papers,
many of which he dictated
and his scribe wrote down, and
many of which had a signature
at the end of the document.
So there was probably some
influence from Rumphius,
but not so much in the
18th century as I can see.
Mainly in the 19th and the 20th centuries,
as well as the 17th century
when he was reporting back
to Batavia constantly.
- Thank you.
- While people collect their
thoughts, I have a question.
As you were giving your talk,
I couldn't help, but think to myself
that your one more addition
to the paper chain in a sense.
You're writing a
dissertation about the way
in which people are
referring to other texts
and the text appear and they reappear.
And in a sense, they reappear
on your PowerPoint here as well.
And so I wondered if you
could tell us the difference
and why does this period matter
and why does this place matter?
Specifically, so if you're
doing, in some sense,
you could argue that you're
doing the same thing,
but you are not in the same place in time.
And so does the meaning
change of the process,
or is it a kind of
universal historical process
that you're hinting at, but
then takes on a specific meaning
in a particular place in time?
And so I'm wondering if
you could then reflect
on how this is specific in
a way to the 18th century
and to Dutch colonialism in this region
and then how that differentiates it
to being a Princeton
scholar writing about it
in the 21st century.
- No, Erik, thank you so
much for that question.
Yeah, it's strange kind
of take a step back
from the dissertation writing
and reflect on the fact
that this kind of paper chain continues
upto the present day.
And of course there are clear parallels
between the way that these VOC clerics
and administrators governing an empire
use the archive to write
about these islands,
not only ethnographically,
but historically,
and for policy and regulation purposes.
I think I see this process happening
in multiple ways and I'll come back
to how I think of my role in all of this.
The latest translator, for
example of Rumphius' verbal,
Ian Batemon, I recently found out
was also kind of collaborating
with a pharmaceutical company
in the U.S.
And so like every kind
of mediating process,
whether that's collecting,
documenting, translating,
circulating similar information
and various versions
has these on the ground and impacts
that I hope to kind of go into
the present day for the book.
But I think my role is to
kind of focus on the history
of mediation and its influence
in order to make this a
little more as historians,
self-reflexive about the craft we practice
and how every kind of historical
document that we're reading
is buttressed by all kinds
of mediating influences
and elements of uncertainty.
So it's certainly been
humbling, but at the same time,
I am very much aware that I
too am repeating their words
and I guess it's just
one way of exploring,
but also critiquing the
way we narrate the past.
So yeah.
- Thank you for this,
it's very interesting.
There's a lot to think about there.
There's a question, I don't
know if you can see it
in the chat.
Can you see the chat window
from Elizabeth Osborn?
I can read it out loud or Elizabeth,
if you would like to ask your question,
you can unmute and do so.
Okay, I'll do it, Elizabeth.
I'll read it to you and that
way everyone can see it.
It says, "My apologies if this
was covered at the beginning.
"Can you mention a bit
more on the practice
"of slavery in Banda, any sense
of how many people enslaved
"and from where and
whether intergenerational
"or time bound within the
lifetime of an enslaved person?"
- Yeah, so I can go into it a little bit,
though I don't really specialize
on the history of slavery in Banda.
There are others, particularly
in the Netherlands
who really delve deeply into this.
There is some debate, I
think among historians
about whether the practice of slavery
in the Eastern archipelago is
kind of a unique case in Asia
where it's much more
reminiscent of slavery
in the Atlantic world, or
whether it's kind of part
of the much more kind of a
household slavery system,
which Anthony Reed writes about.
I don't really have much of a sense
of which might be correct,
but after the Banda massacre
in the early 17th century,
the local overseers
where basically the Dutch
were brought in and were in
charge of Bandanese slaves,
but also other slaves who
were brought into Banda
from all over the archipelago.
And over time, by the
end of the 17th century,
which might talk kind of touched on,
the overseers are no longer
identified as European or Dutch,
or even people who have like Dutch blood.
They're much more seen as
Bandanese at that point
because many of them had married locally.
But the slaves are also
considered Bandanese
and sometimes they are
identified ethnically
as being from different
parts of the archipelago.
I mean, it's a really fascinating case
of how identification based on ethnicity
and based on the name of the island
kind of comes into being
in this part of the world
where of course after the massacre,
you have a great
reduction of local people,
but by the end of the century,
you have this repopulation through force.
So I'm not sure if that
answers your question,
but it is, I believe, I
think it is a lifetime
over the course of a person's lifetime
that they serve as slaves, but
I would have to check that.
- Thanks, there's another
question in the chat
for someone with the Tiano
Reed has unstable wifi.
So it says, you mentioned at the beginning
that you weren't sure
if the original quote
was spoken by Soliman or
that you had questions
about its authenticity, can you say more?
And I'm wondering if he was
specifically being recited
and held up as some kind of "genuine"
or authentic local voice.
- Yeah, I had someone ask
me this question previously
in a different setting,
and it's really unclear
to me how it's possible
to kind of site Soliman
word for word in Dutch,
mainly because we also
don't know what language
they were speaking in
at the council meetings.
So I'm not sure that it's a translation
and also just substantively,
it didn't make sense
in the context that they were in,
that the company was asking
to reduce the number of cloves
and yet Soliman's retort
suggests that he was being asked
to deal with more cloves.
And so that's certainly an
question and I hope it was clear
that, like, I also think I
have my doubts about this.
But the important thing is
that for the administrators
who were working with it in this system,
it didn't really matter
whether they thought
it was true or not.
They could provide evidence
by sending somebody as witness
to the event to Batavia
and testify in person.
And of course, the
clerks and administrators
were so incredibly meticulous to a point
where as I'm tracing his
words in multiple documents
across the century,
there is no misspelling
or changing of the actual quote.
I mean, they're incredibly
meticulous in writing it down
in the same way, it's
just that interpreter
as if it's kind of frozen in time.
And then the interpretations
around the quote
changes over time.
Yeah, I mean, they're citing
local indigenous people
all the time.
This is not something that's unique.
So I don't really think
that they were being recited
as kind of an authentic indigenous voice,
but more as evidence
or different arguments
at the time that they were writing.
So of course, in 1709 as Van
Hoorn was citing Soliman,
he's using it to argue that the company
had somehow tainted
local people's character.
And it doesn't have much
to do with authenticity,
but that here is this evidence
that this Ambonese person
has changed, he is not compliant.
And of course by 1775,
they're citing him again,
not to say that the company administrators
tainted this man's
character, but out of fear
that people are not gonna be
happy with just a fixed price
based on bundled
calculations from the cost
and the cost of probes
previous five years.
So it's kind of an evidence
for how they think the
indigenous people will react
to certain policies, but I don't think
it's just about this kind of unique,
authentic indigenous voice.
- Thank you, we have a
question from Al Lim.
- Hi, thank you so much
for your presentation.
I'm not a historian, but I'm just curious
about kind of the
correlations coming a bit more
from like an anthropological side,
specifically with Batavia
and the kind of relationship
on the colonial relationship.
So you're talking about the
governor who wrote the letter
to the Batavia.
I'm wondering kind of, if you
could speak a little more,
who is on the receiving end
and thinking about how they,
and in the top...
Right up, you talked
about how there was a need
to resolve the present
dilemmas for what they believe
to be a better future and
this kind of paper chain.
So I'm wondering who is the one
kind of shaping this future?
What future did they kind of imagine,
and kind of like who was the one deciding
that they need to convert
this natural history knowledge
into an economically valuable one
and kind of like who is on the other side?
Thank you.
- Yeah, thank you so
much for that question.
There's kind of a clear
hierarchy within the company.
And of course, administrators
stationed in Batavia
are much more powerful than administrators
stationed in these other
port cities like Ambon.
Ambon actually becomes
this weird training ground
to get a position as a
high ranking administrator
in Batavia.
But of course, within the kind
of European company sphere,
the clerks, the marginalists
and the archivists
are also not, I mean, they're
kind of low in the hierarchy.
We don't really hear their voices,
all we have or their signatures.
But they were part of the system
of using the archive to
basically collect information
from the past for forming
present resolutions.
And of course, much of this
is going on in Batavia,
but this paper chain moves all
the way from outer provinces,
like in outer provinces
in Ambon to Batavia
and from Batavia to Amsterdam.
So ultimately all of these
reports are being written
for the governor general in Batavia,
but also those in Amsterdam
who are much more powerful
than anyone stationed
in these port cities.
And of course like the
people who are the least
or just have no power within this process,
I would say are kind of
people like Assam Soliman,
whose voices we think we
hear, but we're left in doubt
as to whether that was
actually what he said,
whether he's being
interpreted in the right way.
And of course, even when
I talk about the knowledge
of slaves from Banda,
it's not as if we have
their voices in the sense.
It's much more about really
collecting information,
rather than kind of in
any way, trying to revive
their agency within these documents.
And I'm a bit wary of doing that
mainly because it's kind
of like, who am I to do it?
But also it's interesting
to see that by looking
at the paper chains, one realizes that...
I mean, I think I could
have written this chapter
on this paper just solely
focusing on Assam Soliman
about whom I have a
little more information,
which I didn't present today.
But ultimately it became a
case of how the structure,
which I've outlined here of
information being recycled
in the archive completely
overpowering any kind of voice
I can trace, which I've
tried really hard to do.
So thank you for your question on power.
It's everywhere and also kind of nowhere.
So thank you.
- I don't see any other questions,
but I'm gonna ask one last question.
It's kind of a theoretical question,
but you mentioned the word
agency in the documents
and you're a little wary about that.
And I was pleasantly
surprised in your talk,
how you didn't go down the pathway
that's almost predictable nowadays
when people talk about
documents is in the agency
of the non-human of the document
and all of these kinds of things,
which is interesting
theoretically in many ways.
But sometimes it departs
from the actual material
so much that you kind of
lose the story a little bit,
but it does raise a question for me.
I'm curious like what you think
about the kind of literature
and things going on
about the agency of
documents and all that.
You've certainly, you must be
thinking about some of that
a little bit as you write,
but you have a unique approach
to it, it seems.
I wonder if you could articulate the way
you think about those things.
- Yeah, no, thank you so
much for this question.
It is something I'm considering,
but ultimately I think my
whole project is kind of based
on the power of reading
and the power of reading
and interpreting and changing
value and the information
that people have collected
and read in the past,
which kind of goes into my
writing about mediation,
that these documents don't...
I think that it's really the
people who are kind of behind
the documents who have the most agency
and yet are not exactly talked about,
and particularly in
the context of the VOC.
So, yeah, I haven't really
mentioned the agency
of archival documents so much
as the agency of the clerks
and the archivists who are
actively compiling information
and organizing that information.
And of course, along the way,
the transformation that
happens as they reinterpret
or selectively extract shorter passages
from longer resolutions.
There are decisions being
made that I don't think
that historians have fully
considered when they read
their historical documents.
For example, the first
part of my presentation,
the documents have the
date of the extracts,
which would be from like 1703 to 1715,
but they don't have the
date for when those extracts
were collected.
One would have to figure
out the names of the clerks
and then trace the names of the clerks
in the VOC little name
books in order to figure out
when they were extracted
and for what purposes.
And so I think that's a good
case of showing that like
a lot of these documents
have been mediated
well for a very long period of time.
And even within a very
short period of time,
if I talk about Rumphius,
all of those documents
have been mediated in certain ways,
whether it's changing indigenous
knowledge or using a scribe
to dictating and using a
scribe to document certain
information, copies of copies of copies,
many of which are very different.
And so I'm not sure that
the object has as much power
as I would like to imbue them.
I think it's really the people
who are kind of invisible
or have not been talked about
where for a much more powerful.
And I try to be honest about that.
Yeah.
- It's interesting.
I was thinking a little bit
about the system itself,
having a kind of compulsion
to it as well, though,
for example, when you mentioned
that very important shift
from listing by date and discovering
that that conceals things or something,
and then does the desire to change it
to an alphabetical system, right?
But once you shift to
an alphabetical system,
you have to fill in a through Z, right.
And eventually that itself
generates a certain kind process,
say, you've finished A,
well, then you're not done,
you know you have to do B
and it creates a kind of
like compulsion within itself
that is quite interesting.
But the initial process is
started by a desire to shift.
So it's quite interesting.
- Yeah, it's kind of...
I found it really interesting
that they didn't have
the system in the 17th
century that at something
that started very much
in the 18th century,
the shift from, well,
it's not a complete shift
because these resolutions are
still being written by date.
It's just that now they
have this massive index
to be able to organize that information.
But yeah, it's certainly
kind of the way of thinking.
And there isn't just one index,
this is kind of a process
that spans most of the 18th century.
So there are multiple registers,
which are then later compiled
and printed in the 19th
and 20th centuries.
And you know, in the 19th
century print edition,
they will say, "Oh, this is for students
"who might be curious about
the history of the VOC."
So students can actually
use the index to search for,
I guess, thesis topics or something.
And just to see if there
are enough documents
about that one topic.
So it is definitely kind of a major shift
in thinking about how to
research the VOC past.
- I think if there's no further questions,
I'm gonna bring the talk to a close.
So I'll stop the recording now
and I'll leave the window
open for a few more minutes
for informal conversation after that,
but please everyone join
me in thanking Genie Yoo
for such a fascinating
talk and wonderful Q&A.
So thank you.